all right jenny yes jenny where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
i'm from a town outside of chicago i was
born in calumet city in illinois
but lived in gary indiana that's gary
it's a very different city than chicago
yeah it is uh
but it's close but yeah it's it's about
20 minutes outside of there yeah
it's pretty much 100 black down there
yeah uh
growing up i was
pretty much the only white girl yeah
what was your childhood like
uh mom and dad
mom
dad wasn't around he
was incarcerated about two weeks after i
was born for manslaughter
he
was a very racist man
from what i was told in his past and
he was in a bar he thought a black man
stole his coat when he went to the
bathroom
he waited for the man to go outside
and he beat him to death
later finding out that his coat was
sitting on the bar stool the whole time
so he was gone until i was about five
uh just me and mom
but being a single mom she was never
there working all the time she was a
great mom
great but like i said she just she had
pity bills
um
spent a lot of time with babysitters
little houses dirty houses
lots of kids
uh first babysitter was great
after that you know she
was hard on money so it got to be you
know friends
dads you know friends dads uh that's
kind of when the molesting started
i was never raped
i was
molested in every other way that you
could be molested though
[Music]
by three different men
i
started getting into gains
at the age of 11
being the only white girl
i think they kind of liked that
i knew how to fight
at a very young age just because i was
white
i had to
i had to protect myself in school my
first fight actually was with a boy a
black boy
um
but
i got into the latin queens
my best friend was a boy i've always
hung out with boys
i think because of my childhood but
we snuck out one night to go to a fair
and my best friend and all were
we was walking over a bridge
and a drive-by occurred and he ended up
getting shot in the neck bled out right
in front of me
about three minutes
took the ambulance about
15 minutes to get there
i'll never forget that
after that
my mom decided she needed to get me out
of that area
she moved me
to a smaller town in indiana
for high school you know stuff like that
i actually did very well in high school
of course i got into drugs
um
more like psychedelic drugs i would say
in high school i've never been a pot
smoker
started doing acid ecstasy
uh
early 20s
i uh
i started
getting with men
who
i think reminded me of my father because
i did spend some time with him
throughout my teens
he abused me every time i was with him
um so i didn't spend that much time with
him
uh abused you huh
physically
like a man i mean
i would be held up against the wall
choked off the ground punched in the
face i've had a hammer thrown at my head
it
i would try to tell my mom about it so i
wouldn't have to go there and
i mean i don't know if maybe she needed
child support or what but she would have
to send me oh a big thing i left out um
when i was going with him
[Music]
he was remarried and i have a younger
sister
i love her to death
the woman that he remarried
she is my wicked stepmother she's
deceased now and i hate to say this but
i am
grateful that she is
worst woman in the world she would
steal my clothes send me home in rags
for her daughter she would keep them for
her daughter she would feed me
rotten food
at the house
get me purposely sick
the last time i saw her
i'm sorry the last time i spoke with her
her and my father
called my house
i had to say i was probably
13 12 13 years old
they called my house about two three in
the morning
high
off cocaine i'm just obliterated
uh my dad
told me he was gonna shoot me in the
face with a shotgun
and
she was instigating it and instigating i
don't know why this woman just was very
jealous of me
she hated me
like i said she ended up
overdosing
about seven years ago
and i paid my respects i went to her
funeral
everything
the family actually asked me to speak at
her funeral i don't know why but i
didn't
um
like i was saying into my 20s
i started
getting with just these horrible men who
i think i just wanted to fix them
you know they
just bad boys you know
i got pregnant the ma my ex-husband who
i was with for 12 years he's currently
incarcerated
um
[Music]
he purposely got me pregnant because he
didn't have anywhere to go
and
i'd say about a year
after
yeah about a year after i had that child
um
is when i got into drugs
my life was him and he never was abusive
he was mentally
and verbally abusive but never
physically
but he could really
really talk me down
he
would never come home he was a
really bad drinker really bad drinker he
would cheat on me all the time
so i started using drugs
um
i started with pills
just like every other heroin addict um
and it eventually it progressed to
heroin
now it's fentanyl
and because of that i'm on the streets
and
i don't talk to my family anymore
because i don't want to burden them
i think what's my problem
i don't want to ask them for anything um
my children are
i have two children two girls um
i gave up temporary custody of them
to their father's aunt
it's a wonderful woman they have a great
life
um i think it's honestly the most
unselfish thing i've ever done
thank you
um
just in case
but
but yeah um
that's my biggest regret that i don't
like talk to anybody anymore i'll talk
to my kids every once in a while on
facebook
but like my mom
she was always my best friend always and
when i started doing heroin i just
i got really ashamed
and just went off on my own and
you know
she um
when i got pregnant with my first
daughter
she actually my mom got pregnant too we
found out the same day
that we were pregnant she was 43
so
my younger sister and my daughter are
two weeks apart
and because i don't talk to my mom
they don't even talk the two girls
and
they're just heartbreaking to me
um
but yeah since i've been on the streets
it's uh
it's hard
especially being a girl
especially being a girl um
i've never been raped or anything like
that i've been beaten though i've been
kidnapped
i had a man
in climate city actually
i ended up back there
i had a man
lock me in his basement for three weeks
uh you only gave me water
a little bit of food every once in a
while like every two days
um
he was a drug dealer
and he ended up doing one of his own
drugs one night and he left the door
unlocked and i just i booked it
and
after that
i ended up going to memphis
with a guy
um
on the way to memphis
he beat me
and
i remember
once i became homeless i started
carrying a knife
always just for protection for me
i remember when this man beat me
i was seriously about to stab him in
this car
but we was in the middle of nowhere
and i just remember thinking i have to
be in this car i can't just be stuck in
the middle of nowhere i have no phone i
have no money i have nothing
um so i ended up
going to memphis with this man for three
months
beat all the time
[Music]
from there my habit just got worse
i mean i can
i try to
drown out i guess
the things that i think about
with the drugs but i have such a high
tolerance that i just do too much
and i i'll end up overdosing or
i've overdosed 17 times
on fentanyl yeah no on heroin actually
yeah
fentanyl for some reason it's supposed
to be stronger but for me it's not
my body is
different
i don't know why
i have no top i have
an incredibly high tolerance for
morphine it doesn't even do anything to
me like
um but
i ended up getting back to chicago
that was a fun trip
um
when i got back to chicago
that man had come with me um
by the grace of god he had a warrant out
of texas
and uh
he was caught panhandling and taken to
texas on that warrant so
i was away from him
um
and
now on the streets by myself
again
um just trying to survive that's when i
started panhandling
i never realized how much money i could
make doing it
um
actually at first i didn't make anything
i really didn't know what i was doing i
kept my head down all the time i didn't
look at people
and
it took about a about two months
but i started making enough money to
feed my habit
um
feed myself
you know um
i was staying in an abandoned hotel at
the time
with a couple of friends
um and it's funny to say uh
the man that
that had gone back gotten you know
shipped to texas
his friend was there
and he was the only person you know that
i really knew
uh that was five years ago
his friend to this day is still my
boyfriend
he uh
same situation as me
great man he's never
laid a hand on me i mean he'll yell at
me but you know but
but he's you know a drug addict like me
um
panhandles like me
um
[Music]
and this is our life now
i mean we
where are you living
we live uh in a tent
um
on koenga in hollywood
uh
there's about 10 other tents there
we're waiting currently to
get into project room key
uh we've been waiting on that for a very
long time to get housing yeah to get
housing um
i think being that i'm not from
california
maybe that's taking longer
um
but yeah i mean every day now is just
the same thing over and over we
panhandle we get our drugs we go home we
go to sleep we wake up
uh
i mean when i was in chicago
i had some things happen
we were in chicago for about five years
yeah about five years because we just
recently came here about six months ago
um
but yeah i mean in chicago
and i'm talking
in chicago the west side of chicago you
know it's an open-air drug market so
that's where we got our drugs all black
neighborhoods all black all black yeah
um
you're down there for so long you're
respected kinda you respect them they
respect you
um but
i've been beaten i've been robbed
i've been pistol whipped that's my teeth
um
is that where your teeth are missing
yeah
my front teeth well it started with my
front teeth and now it's progressively
going back to the other ones
um
me and him both we were
hit in the face with uh
a two by four
i'll never forget that broke my nose
busted my eyes i was bleeding from my
eyes
that was
wow
just for being in somebody's garage it
wasn't even his it was an abandoned
garage
that we just went in to get warm
this guy beat us
other than that i mean
just day to day trying to survive now
i'm 37
so i've been doing this almost all my
adult life
um
do you have contact with your kids
occasionally uh
they message me you know on facebook and
they're older now they're 16 and 13 you
know my 16 year old
she wants to know where i've been and i
don't know what to tell her you know and
my mom i want to call my mom i want to
talk to her so bad
but i don't know what to say i mean
why would i have not called her for the
last five years you know
like what
really could have
prevented me from calling her it's
nothing
it's nothing at all it's a shame it's
yeah
it's just me
being ashamed not wanting to bother her
you know because she's got a whole
nother life now she's got a whole other
kid
um
her husband has
uh stage four lung cancer i honestly had
a great man my stepfather great man
he actually was a heroin addict too from
vietnam
so
when i was with them you know he
me and him were very close and uh
he
he helped me through a lot
and
yeah now that he got sick i just i feel
like i really should have been
there and not being there kills me it
really does
my kids not being there you know not
talking to them at all kills me
um but i think a lot of it i've always
been a runner my whole life i mean even
when i was little you know and then
things would happen to me
i remember trying to tell my mom one
time you know that
this man was touching me inappropriately
she didn't believe me and i don't know
if she didn't believe me because
she needed me to have somewhere to go or
because it was her friend's dad
or
what but nothing ever came of it and i
had to keep going back there to it
and
then we had a my aunt married this man
who started touching me and my sister
and that never came out i mean until we
were like 18
you know and as
i was never
nobody ever believed us
and so i think i just finally you know
said screw it and just stop
kept it all to myself
you know even to this day that people
really don't know my story
they don't know what i've been through
and it's
i really don't like talking about it
if it does it makes me emotional
um
do you feel like that was the biggest
factor in your
current situation oh yeah going through
all that yeah
definitely it changes a woman forever
doesn't it changes the person forever
yes it does
it does and i mean it's
it's crazy the simplest little horrible
memories that i have
my very first memory that i remember
was
my mom was dating this man
i don't know if she had a thing for
prejudice men or what but this man was
prejudiced too
she bought me
i had to be two years old
um
when i asked her that's what she said i
was probably about two
she bought me a malibu stacy barbie or
something like that but the barbie was
really tan
and this man
thought that the barbie was black and he
snapped it in half right in front of me
it was like my very first toy ever you
know
because we didn't have money
ever you know she worked at a pizza
place
she still does till this day actually
um
she owns it now actually though
but
you know just little things like that
my memories they're all just
very morbid and disturbing and
i don't have too many happy memories
especially once uh once my dad got out
of prison you know and i started having
to spend that little time with him and
the stepmother issues and
the gang life
the gang life i'm really glad i didn't
get that much into because i know
i would be dead at this point
so
i'm glad that you know she got me out of
there and did what she had to do you
know she seen that i was
taking a pass that was going to get me
killed even though this path could get
me killed
yeah so what's your biggest fear
my biggest fear is
dying and nobody knowing that i even
died
just overdosing somewhere
being put into a plain wooden box
with the drug you're playing around with
it yeah
especially with how long i've been doing
it
did your sexual abuse as a kid ever lead
you to do sexual work as an adult no
that's something
i think it actually
sexually kind of
repressed me because i'm very shy
when it comes to stuff like that
um
i've never prostituted i've never
stripped nothing like that
um
and i'm very proud of that actually
because most of these girls out here
that is what they do yeah the men too
yeah yeah men too
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
keep your family close
because that is my biggest regret
just keep your family close because
they're really all you have
at the end of the day
because i know i can call my family
still to this day and they would take me
back
i don't know if they would forgive me
but
you know if i was clean and
trying to change my life yeah they would
still be there you know where most
people friends and stuff wouldn't
so yeah just keep your family close
don't ever let that go especially your
kids
especially your kids
what emotions do you go through no what
emotions now yeah are you depressed
very
i get
very depressed all the time
i think it's just
because of our lifestyle it's
so repetitive and
[Music]
just the same thing
you know and it's leading me nowhere
you know i just wake up every day to do
the same thing
to just
i do a drug that doesn't even have an
effect on me anymore i'm just normal
from it you know
[Music]
it's such a waste of time so it's a
waste of money i don't know why i even
do it but i have to i have to to keep
myself well otherwise i'm
viciously sick
do you think you'll be on the streets
for the rest of your life or do you see
yourself getting away
i hope not
but i'm the kind of person
i think the worst and hope for the best
you know so
i could see myself
honestly being on the streets till i die
just because
it's a way of lifestyle that i've grown
used to
you know everybody hates change
but i don't want to be
i don't want to
if you could have changed something
about your
your youth your childhood what would you
have changed
oh other than other than being molested
as a kid
trying to spend more time with my mom
just
you know because she was never around
because she really she was a great
parent you know she did everything that
she could
i mean she put herself in the major debt
you know trying to do things
you know for christmas presents
things like that
um
i just i really wish i would have gotten
to be a lot closer to her especially
when i was little
because i think you know
i could have turned out i know i could
have turned out
a different way
because like i said when i went to high
school i was great i got straight a's
all through high school
um
i was accepted into the chicago artists
who got a full scholarship wow yeah
i ended up losing that
um
yeah i mean i know i have it in me i
just
i'm a follower
you know somebody's doing something
it's like
let's try that
i never thought i'd get addicted heroin
but
that's what happened
all right jenny thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you i wish you the best of luck
thank you thank you very much
you